these mountains in Bolivia are where
quinoa grows a gluten-free grain like
plant that's cropped mainly for its
edible seeds quinoa is rich in protein
amino acids and minerals it doesn't need
much water to grow and can survive in
poor soil un experts say quinoa could
play an important role in fighting
hunger around the world for centuries
quinoa was more or less ignored by the
rest of the world but in recent years
this grain like crop from the Andes has
increased in popularity people from all
over are now buying our quinoa you can
even find it at the markets in la paz if
we have a surplus at the end of the
harvest we can sell it now
the main market in La Paz is famous for
the variety of fruits and vegetables
sold here there are more than 2,000
different kinds of quinoa and some of
them are on sale here but some people
selling quinoa have mixed feelings about
the grains newfound popularity
I've heard that a bank of quinoa now
sells overseas for $25 will not leave it
up being that means we'll have less of
it to sell here it'll be too expensive
no a mooch aquino e-commerce banker ooh
much of Bolivia's quinoa crop is now
processed by machines to make it more
competitive on international markets
bolivia produces an estimated thirty
eight thousand tons of quinoa a year and
that's expected to increase 70% of the
crop is exported quinoa has long been
available in local restaurants and
salads for example or in vegetarian
burritos
restaurant owners like Pammy Quezada
keep coming up with innovative ways to
serve quinoa she even features homemade
quinoa cookies for dessert Quezada says
that public perception of quinoa has
changed for the better
Oh sandwich okay let me tell you that we
spend a lot of time trying to convince
people that quinoa is not just food for
the lower classes and people are
gradually beginning to discover that
quinoa has a lot to offer the UN has
officially declared 2013 the
International Year of quinoa the
Bolivian government provides financial
aid for quinoa farmers and offers
courses on how quinoa can be used in
foods we had no idea that quinoa was
such a healthy plant we used to sell all
the quinoa we harvested and we'd eat
noodles instead now we won't eat
anything else we use quinoa in soups
juice bread and pastries you can use it
in almost anything estamos haciendo de
la king
and the increased production of quinoa
has helped many farmers improve their
standard of living
you
you